brasil llevó a cabo su elección más
inusual desde el retorno de la
democracia en 1985 con el obligado uso
de mascarillas y el gel desinfectante
como protagonistas la pandemia de kobe
19 marcó los comicios municipales del
domingo aplazados varias semanas por el
virus que deja casi 6 millones de
contagios en el país creo que la
política siempre es importante
independientemente de que estamos
viviendo una situación de pandemia la
gente siempre tiene que ejercer el
derecho al voto la votación por la que
se designan a los cinco mil 569 alcaldes
y concejales municipales de la mayor
economía de américa latina es también un
pulso a las políticas del presidente
yair bolsonaro que pondrán a prueba la
fuerza del giro a la derecha de la
nación y que según adelanta los
analistas será una victoria para los
conservadores con una gran cantidad de
candidatos evangélicos y ex integrantes
de las fuerzas de seguridad brasileñas
por su parte el ex vicepresidente
izquierdista luiz inácio lula da silva
arremetió contra boston ar por sonar
bolsonaro es posiblemente el mayor
desastre político del país
y creo que en muchos años a partir de
ahora alguna milicia algunos fanáticos
pueden inventar algo útil que
evolucionar o hizo por el país la
jornada transcurrió con dificultades en
el estado norteño de amapá debido al
racionamiento de luz y con la mitad del
electorado tras un aplazamiento de los
comicios en la capital macapá por
cuestiones de seguridad